la seule souveraineté c'est le peuple et
le président de la République fait appel
à lui en cas de conflit il n'y a pas de
méthode plus démocratique et plus
libéral si l'on veut rester dans un
régime de liberté
monsieur le ministre l'une des
principales objections que certains font
à la nouvelle constitution de ce sont
les pouvoirs exceptionnels qui sont
accordés au président de la République
de votre sentiment je vais vous lire
l'article c'est une chose que devrait
faire plus souvent les contradicteurs
que dit l'article 16 lorsque les
institutions de la République
l'indépendance de la nation l'intégrité
de son territoire où l'exécution de ces
engagements internationaux sont menacés
d'une manière grave et immédiate et que
le fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics constitutionnels est interrompu
le président de la République prend les
mesures exigées par les circonstances
c'est un article exceptionnel et une
constitution qui est faite pour durer
doit prévoir surtout à l'époque que nous
vivons des moments difficiles et pour
ces moments difficiles fixez les
responsabilités donner les pouvoirs
nécessaires et il est apparu d'une
manière qui ne peut pas être contestée
que c'est le président de la République
garant de la légitimité nationale qui
doit porter ses responsabilités et qui
doit par conséquent exercer
éventuellement les pouvoirs nécessaires
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
exemple de ces moments difficiles tels
qu'on peut les imaginer
nous n'avons pas le droit
de ne pas
envisager l'hypothèse de troubles
profonds dans le monde suite de conflits
graves suite même de conflit atomiques
nous n'avons pas le droit d'éliminer une
hypothèse de subversion intérieure ce
sont des cas qui exigent que si le
fonctionnement des pouvoirs publics est
gravement atteint la légitimité
républicaine et l'Ordre national soit
sauvegardé par quelqu'un qui en est la
responsabilité bon et bien leur monsieur
le ministre maintenant le comprenons
mieux nous voyons qu'il peut y avoir des
cas exceptionnels évidemment très
exceptionnels mais est-ce que tout de
même d'après la nouvelle Constitution le
président de la République ne sera pas
tenté de pouvoir pas être tenté de faire
assez mauvais usages de ses pouvoirs
exceptionnels encore une fois lisons
l'article
il est dit que le Président de la
République en tel circonstance doit
consulter le Premier ministre les
présidents des assemblées les conseils
constitutionnels il est dit que le
Parlement se réunit de plein droit et il
est dit que le Président de la
République ne peut pas en ce cas
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale qui par
conséquent demeure et siège dès lors où
elle danger en fait c'est une mauvaise
querelle qui vient de ce qu'en France
certains esprits ont toujours été
hostiles à ce que le chef d'État soit
autre chose qu'une personnalité fallotte
sans autorité ni responsabilité il faut
se souvenir de ce que disait un
président de la Troisième République à
la fin de son septennat il disait je
n'ai été qu'une potiche c'est ce qu'il
faut éviter monsieur le ministre alors
oublions les pouvoirs exceptionnels si
vous le voulez bien mais dans la
nouvelle Constitution alors en quoi le
président de la République définit enfin
avec la nouvelle Constitution en quoi
ces pouvoirs en temps normal seront-ils
différents de ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
le projet constitution veut faire du
président de la République comme déjà le
voulait les constituants en 1875 la clé
de voûte du régime parlementaire nous
avons simplement voulu mieux faire que
et en plus le projet de Constitution
prévoit que le Président de la
République a une autre responsabilité
capitale qui est d'être le chef de la
communauté en raison de ces deux
attributions il a des pouvoirs qu'ils
ont des pouvoirs normaux comme dans les
lois 1875 c'est lui qui choisit le
Premier ministre c'est lui qui préside
au destinées de la République et les
articles qui ont trait à ses pouvoirs en
matière diplomatique ou en tant que chef
des armées sont exactement les articles
des lois de 1875 mais en plus il est
vrai comme clé de voûte plus solide du
régime parlementaire le projet prévoit
que le Président de la République peut
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel si
l'estime qu'une loi n'est contraire à la
Constitution il peut saisir le peuple
par référendum
si le gouvernement ou les assemblées lui
demandent sur un sujet important de le
faire il peut enfin comme dans tout
régime parlementaire renvoyé l'assemblée
devant ses électeurs ce sont des
pouvoirs absolument normaux et ils naît
aucun régime parlementaire à l'étranger
ou d'une manière ou de l'autre le
président de la République naissait
pouvoir ajoutons-y alors les pouvoirs
qu'il a en tant que futur chef de la
communauté ou plutôt chef de la future
communauté
il est il préside le Conseil exécutif il
saisit le Sénat de la Communauté il est
la clé de voûte de l'association
franco-africaine et pour ce faire il a
les pouvoirs normaux d'un chef de
communauté ayant des responsabilités
considérables vous venez bien monsieur
le ministre un instant que le Président
de la République aurait des pouvoirs
normaux il est bien certain en tout cas
qu'il aura et du pouvoir élargi quand au
collège électoral qui va les lire il
sera plus important et certains
justement se demandent si dans au cours
du scrutin enfin si il la campagne
n'aura pas les campagnes disons n'auront
pas une part excessive une prépondérance
bien plus grande que les villes et là il
y a il y a une inquiétude je crois
l'expérience des lois de 75 a bien
montré que les pouvoirs du Président de
la République n'étaient pas en fait
exercer parce que l'assise électorale du
chef de l'État n'était pas assez large
et faisait de lui simplement un arbitre
entre les parties il faut faire plus
l'expérience la montrer dès lors le
collège électoral est aujourd'hui dans
le projet composé des mers des conseils
municipaux des conseillers municipaux et
qui viennent avec les conseillers
généraux et les parlementaires faire un
immense corps électoral de 80000
électeurs environ
les électeurs du seigle et de la
châtaigne a dit un professeur qui
parfois
a été trop sévère
seigle et châtaignes
c'est absolument une image faux d'abord
voyons ce qu'est la France la France est
sociologiquement une nation ou les
communes et les petites villes ont une
grande importance si on veut une
représentation légitime de la France il
faut bien prendre ce que la France est
d'autre part si l'on veut un collège
politique on n'a pas le choix le collège
politique de la France c'est le collège
de ses élus et enfin il y a beaucoup de
mauvaise foi car un effort considérable
a été fait pour donner aux villes
moyennes et aux grandes villes une
importance
à la hauteur de leurs habitants en
particulier en ce qui concerne toutes
les villes de plus de 30 000 habitants
leur représentation grâce à des
électeurs supplémentaires fait qu'ils ne
sont pas sous-représentées par rapport à
la moyenne des communes françaises c'est
dire que le collège électoral du
président de la République est à mon
avis le meilleur que l'on puisse trouver
monsieur le ministre va lui poser une
question que beaucoup de spectateurs
beaucoup d'électeurs en tout cas du 28
septembre sont déjà posés j'en suis
certain est-ce que un tel président tel
que vous venez de le dépeindre ne va pas
entrer en conflit souvent enfin je ne
vois pas de façon permanente mais enfin
souvent avec le Parlement
l'essence de la démocratie c'est le
conflit il n'y a pas de conflit en
régime de dictatures ou du moins les
confins ne sont pas apparents et se
terminent dans le sang en démocratie la
discussion politique aboutit par la
force des choses à des conflits
on dit la séparation des pouvoirs est
caduques les caduques du point de vue de
la doctrine mais s'il n'y a pas une
certaine séparation des responsabilités
on aboutit soit à la confusion c'est
bien ce que nous avons vu soit à la
dictature c'est bien ce que l'on pouvait
voir le rôle du président de la
République est de régler les conflits
entre le gouvernement et le Parlement et
les règles non pas tant par ces pouvoirs
propres de décision mais par le fait qui
seullicite la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel ou qui sollicite la
décision par référendum ou par
dissolution que veut-on dire le
président de la République créerait un
conflit par exemple c'est le seul cas où
il voudrait être imposer à l'Assemblée
nationale un premier ministre que dans
celle-ci ne voudrait pas et à qui elle
refuserait la confiance il n'y a qu'une
manière de régler le conflit et pour le
président de la République de marquer
son autorité c'est de donner la parole
au peuple par voie de dissolution et la
peur du suffrage populaire est en vérité
faire penser de tous ceux qui critiquent
car ils demeure dans cette idée qu'il
est absolument pas républicaine que la
souveraineté nationale est donnée à une
assemblée en réalité il n'y a pas
d'assemblée souveraine la seule
souveraineté c'est le peuple et le
président de la République fait appel à
lui en cas de conflit il n'y a pas de
méthode plus démocratique et plus
libéral si l'on veut rester dans un
régime de liberté oui mais monsieur le
ministre vous venez de parler de
dissolution et qui dit solution dit
ouais électorale et justement la
Constitution la nouvelle Constitution
elle n'en souffle mot n'en parle pas le
gouvernement n'avait pas le pouvoir de
traiter de la loi électorale et d'autre
part c'est une tradition peut-être
contestable mais c'est une tradition que
en France les constitutions le prêtent
pas de la loi électorale en ce qui
concerne les députés ni les sénateurs
donc c'est une loi spéciale qui sera
prise après le référendum comme cela a
été annoncé par le général de Gaulle
le but de toute loi électoral le but de
tous scrutin est d'essayer d'obtenir une
majorité cohérente qui est en fin de
compte la première des conditions pour
un bon régime parlementaire c'est en
France une tâche très difficile à la
fois à cause de la multiplicité des
parties et à cause aussi de ce fait
traditionnel et sociologique que la
France est un pays très divisé le
meilleur mode de scrutin c'est le
scrutin anglo-saxon le scrutin
majoritaire à un tour et il n'est
malheureusement pas possible en France
il faut en tout cas s’écarter de la
représentation proportionnelle avec
toutes les additifs souvent contestables
qu'on y a ajouté il faut revenir un
scrutin majoritaire scrutin majoritaire
qui sera par conséquent à deux tours et
la discussion portera sur le cadre de ce
scrutin soit département soit
circonscription uninominale je souhaite
personnellement que ce soit une première
étape et que les mœurs parlementaires
s'assainissant on approche du scrutin
majoritaire du type du scrutin anglais
qui est probablement le meilleur merci
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]